We have some bad hombres here and we're gonna
get 'em out.
Well, that's it, the final debate of 2016
is over.
And everyone's talking about the same things
we've heard time and again.
Donald thinks belittling women makes him bigger.
Why don't you give back the money that you've
taken from certain countries
that treat certain groups of people so horribly?
And Trump supposedly threatening the very
fabric of our democracy.
That the loser concedes to the winner and
that the country comes together,
in part, for the good of the country,
are you saying
you're not prepared now to commit to that principle-
What I'm saying is that I will tell you at
the time.
I'll keep you in suspense.
Well, Chris, let me respond to that because
that's horrifying.
And then in the last ten minutes of the final
debate of the presidential contest,
we finally talked about a little thing called the debt.
But the non-partisan committee for responsible
federal budgets says that Secretary Clinton,
under your plan debt would rise to 86% of
GDP over the next ten years.
Mr Trump under your plan they say it would
rise to 105% of GDP over the next ten years.
Trump wants to cut taxes and raise spending
while denying that it would explode our debt.
I say they're wrong because I'm going to create
tremendous jobs.
And Clinton wants to raise spending and raise
taxes
while denying that would have any effect on job growth.
We are going where the money is, we are going
to ask the wealthy and corporations
to pay their fair share.
And there is no evidence whatsoever that that
will slow down or diminish our growth,
in fact I think just the opposite.
Most economists accept that high thresholds
of government debt
correlates with low economic growth.
But you didn't get to hear that perspective
in the debates,
brought to you by our wonderful two party system.
This debate is sponsored by the Commission
on Presidential Debates.
So while everyone's talking about rigged elections,
leaked emails and puppets.
No puppet, no puppet... you're the puppet.
Remember that both candidates will run up
the debt, oppose free trade, deport more immigrants
and likely mire us in endless middle eastern
conflicts.
Happy Voting!